all right so we've seen exorcisms in
movies but have we seen them all
shaky-cam mockumentary style here we go
[Music]
the last exorcism good title you don't
want to commit to a sequel just yet like
Final Fantasy sorta alright so the story
goes the second generation preacher scam
artist money-grubbing douchebag is
convinced that demonic possession is a
condition of the brain in the success of
an exorcism is pretty much based on the
placebo effect so he takes a couple
people and a camera and sets out to
prove it all the while preying on the
gullible and making some cash along the
way now I feel like I've seen this
before so we set that and meets a family
with a possessed girl on what looks like
the set of True Blood and yeah it's a
movie so you know this [ __ ] is just
gonna blow up in his face so as you may
or may not know I have a real soft spot
for those shaky cam mockumentary style
movies and I have a soft spot for
demonic possession exorcism movies I
don't know why I just did so this should
be like Merry Christmas and Happy New
Year to me I'll admit this movie had a
couple of really good things going for
it I had a pretty solid set up and I had
a couple of moments that really pushed
the pg-13 thing poor kitty that cat may
have preferred the dumpster and for some
messed-up reason the preachers
douchiness it just made me laugh I
didn't want to I would hate him if I
knew him in real life but for the movie
it really worked here's a funny douche
bag what can I say and some [ __ ] just
didn't work when the demons talking
through the girl it really wasn't
convincing but I do kind of see why they
did it cuz it's a dynamic that the movie
really plays off of like issue really
possessed is she not is she's just a
crazy girl so it could just be a crazy
girl talking not a demon you're not
supposed to know but that was also the
point of The Exorcism of Emily Rose and
Debra Morgan was awesome but it's okay
cuz you wade through all this [ __ ] and
you wade through the whole slow setup
because you know that a really sweet
exorcism scene is coming at the end of
the movie but not this time I'm not
gonna lie the ending of this movie was
one of those endings that can just ruin
an entire movie for you it did for me I
mean the movie doesn't show us much for
the sake of it feeling more real which
I'm cool with I mean I loved Paranormal
Activity so there you go and then the
end is just this crazy [ __ ] CGI Fez
it felt like end of days yeah not the
event the movie which is probably worse
than the event the end of this movies
like end of days meets Blair Witch
whatever boat they want to be on they
missed it by about a decade so it
doesn't matter I mean just give us a
sweet exorcism you know some solid
good-versus-evil [ __ ] I mean that's all
but nah we get demon fire and stupid so
the movie was okay it had a couple of
creepy scenes it's certainly not the
best possession movie or exorcism movie
out there the girl was okay when the
demon was talking through her and a head
of [ __ ] ending so I'm gonna say it was
okay but you're not going to remember it
in t-minus 13 hours but because of the
dog
I'm gonna bust that down to six hours
before so tonight just YouTube
possessions and exorcisms and all that
[ __ ] with your light off freak yourself
out a hundred times more
no seriously raise your hand if you've
ever YouTubed an exorcism or possession
exactly
[Music]